make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay we're getting into the Phoenix saga
normally we would start this like much
much later right because like the
Phoenix saga movie doesn't really come
out until like June 7th so technically
speaking we don't really have to do it
yet but the way to Chris Claremont did
things it was really really crazy right
now when you go and read you read Marvel
Comics it's just a series of successive
stories and very rarely do you ever find
an instance where like the events of one
story arc impact another right like
they're all basically totally
self-contained and so in order to kind
of preface this we're gonna do a little
bit of explanation here because again
not a whole lot happens you I mean
there's a lot that happens but it's
really more action as opposed to like
actual explanations or anything and so
we can kind of beef this video up a bit
by kind of jumping back a little so when
it comes to the Phoenix saga I do have a
video I think on the Phoenix the Phoenix
force explained but the way that this
played out when it came to this whole
thing with like literally setting in
motion the the Phoenix saga proper it
was reworking Jean Grey right because
when Stan Lee and Jack Kirby wrote the
character of Jean she was a damsel in
distress right like she was the girl who
couldn't do anything on her own and so
it was essentially like the x-men had to
save her all the time particularly
Cyclops he had to rescue her she was
overwhelmed in training sessions it was
like oh you know my hero you know that
kind of thing and so the result was that
by the time the the Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby era came to an end and even going
into guys like Roy Thomas and so on
leading up to the cancellation of x-men
and the reprints from 65s like 93 or
whatever it was what it basically meant
was that Jean Grey was like the weakest
character that nobody cared about and so
whether were attempts to kind of beef up
her character by basically saying like
she always had telepathy but it was
essentially locked away by Charles
Xavier because she couldn't control it
it didn't really make much of a
difference and so one of the first
things Chris Claremont did because this
kicks off with issue number 98 the pre
Lu does Chris Claremont took over for
issues before with issue number 94 I
think it was so like right off the bat
basically within like four months he was
like we're gonna rework Jean Grey and
turn her into like a powerhouse of a
character now the other half of this
really kind of goes into like the thing
the events that lead into really this
and the reason why is because they
didn't really come until after it wasn't
until after the Phoenix saga the Dark
Phoenix saga because it was so popular
that Marvel started releasing stories
that were designed to kind of expand the
explanation that have been given to us
by Chris Klem on some of that happened
in the events of in the events of
classic x-men which are basically
disliked these comics that Chris
Claremont wrote but it essentially was
like extra information that's added in
that wasn't there before but a good bulk
of that really comes from bizarre
adventures number 27
from x-men The Forgotten years so when
it came to his our adventures number 27
this was the tried and true origin of
Jean Grey and she didn't she didn't
really have one back then I mean there
is an updated one although it does leave
out some information from bizarre
adventures but there is a more modern
one than x-men really our moral release
they actually released a series of one
shots they were called x-men origins
that focus on like the origin stories of
characters from the x-men as part of the
lead-up to the films but the idea here
is that initially you had Jean who was
just like a little girl and she had a
friend named Annie and what ended up
happening here was Annie was basically
hit by a car and then died but in that
moment Jean Grae had basically like user
telepathy to reach into the mind of
Annie and experience her last moments
and essentially experience what it meant
to die and what this meant what wound up
happening as a result of this is that
Jean Grey kind of sent out this psychic
signal literally like a giant flare and
it had two effects the first one was
that Charles Xavier picked up on it and
said who in the world is that because
from from Charles Xavier perspective it
was one of the most powerful psychic
readings he'd ever picked up and the
other one who was that the the Phoenix
force from on the other side of the
universe basically recognized it saw
what was going on and then came over to
investigate Jean Grey now we didn't
really know what the Phoenix force did
about Jean for years and years and years
it was just this girl could potentially
be a perfect host for me I'll just wait
and watch this goes into the Forgotten
years and the way that that played out
is the x-men were on a mission with the
Fantastic Four out in space and then
Jean Grey basically just kind of like
went into a catatonic state or at least
from her perspective she kind of blacked
out but in reality what had gone on is a
Phoenix force had taken control of her
body and basically spoken with like that
the Fantastic Four in the x-men and was
like one day I'm gonna take this kid
like I'm gonna take this girl she's
gonna become my perfect host and that's
that's just the way it was kind of a
cool little conversation but again like
it was it was showing that like there
was a reason why Jean Grey was picked it
wasn't arbitrary the other half of this
is this deals with something called
Project wide-awake now we've talked
about white awake before and
specifically this actually goes in a
project Armageddon but project
wide-awake was a commissioned by the
federal government involving multiple
intelligence agencies that was designed
to find a way to contain and control the
mutant threat originally you had ball of
our Trask understand Lee and Jack Kirby
they were the ones who created him he
created the Sentinels and the signals in
turn became like kind of self-aware and
then tried to take over the world and
they were ultimately stopped by the
x-men after Bolivar Trask was defeated
and after he was presumed to have been
dead
all the work he'd done on the signals
was handed over to the federal
government as part of Project wide-awake
and so that information in turn was
given to Stephen Lang and that's when
we'll see a lot of this kind of stuff
unfold but the fact remains that that
when this whole thing happens initially
it's just kind of like the x-men and
Rockefeller Plaza during Chris uh on
Christmas Eve and that's one of the
important things to bear in mind when it
came to Chris Claremont storytelling is
because is that while these sentinels
kind of show up out of nowhere and
literally just like start grabbing them
so you know they grab Jean Grey and they
essentially just kind of like race off
it's the small things that made Chris
Claremont writing important right
because he focused on the characters
that was the nature of it like focus on
the characters let like the events be a
background thing that just kind of
happened to go on around that same time
and that's one of the things he begins
to hit on here is that because there was
kind of a lull between the time that we
saw the original uncanny egg I'm sorry
the original x-men understand Lee and
Jack Kirby and this kind of uncanny
x-men here it basically meant that like
a time period had passed and during that
time period gene gray become a lot more
powerful where their telekinesis and
that's one of the things that that
Claremont hits on the other half of this
is that because he's really kind of like
broad stroking this and saying like
let's just show everybody the powers of
people are they're capable of you know
when it comes to Cyclops it's concussive
blast his optic beams are hugely
powerful they punch a hole right through
these sentinels but that's one of the
big differences here is that while the
Sentinels as you depicted here or
exactly like the ones from x-men the
aminah series since x-men TAS was based
off these this version really like
uncanny x-men under Chris Claremont and
really x-factor as well these sentinels
are not nearly as intelligent as the
ones created by ball of our Trask
well I'll actually find out why here in
a little bit before his part where
Cyclops is kind of able to hold his own
to a degree the issue is that he's met
by overwhelming force and that's what
the signals are designed to be the sheer
amount of concussive energy they can
blast at you is enough to either
incinerate you in your entirety or the
very least knock you out quite easily
and that's kind of what happens with
Cyclops to a degree he sort of
incapacitated and then essentially
defeated the following sentinels
basically end up going after Shaun
Cassidy of rain and storm now Shaun
Cassidy is a character that we haven't
really talked about before but Shaun
Cassidy is a guy named Banshee who
exists out in Cassidy heap he literally
just basically manipulates sonic
frequencies is all it is he can bust
your eardrums out by screaming he can
fly is kind of crazy to watch him just
like scream and fly around it's kind of
weird
[Music]
he certainly was a strange character but
he had basically been part of the
uncanny x-men ever since the events of
giant-size x-men number one right like
when this new team of x-men was
assembled by Xavier in order to save the
original team of Cyclops Jean Iceman
beast and an angel but again storm
Wolverine Banshee they're all basically
kidnapped in addition to Jean Grey and
so that's when the question becomes well
who are they gonna go after next because
they're only taking selectively versions
of us which makes them worried about
Professor Xavier so what we do is we
switch over to a guy named Peter Corbeau
and Xavier proper and of course the two
of them are basically met by the arrival
of a sentinel now Peter Corbeau is
interesting because the idea of Peter
for a bow is he does serve kind of a
significant purpose here but before that
he was a character that showed up in the
old Incredible Hulk stories and credible
1:48 from back in the day but he's
basically like a longtime friend of
Charles Xavier which is why the two of
them are hanging out but it's one of the
big things to notice here as these x-men
face off against these sentinels for the
most part the Sentinels are really kind
of shown to be inept right they're kind
of shown is just not really be effective
it's really kind of like catching them
by surprise and a lot of us because of
the fact that the man behind this who we
switched to at the moment is a guy named
Stephen Lang who's just not I mean he's
he's confident but he's not really able
to build effective sentinels now for
Stephen Lang himself he is effectively
working for the federal government but
the difference here is that while he is
working for the feds in the sense of
like working as part of project wide
awake project Armageddon is his own
personal project as far as the
government's aware he's doing research
on how mutant powers can be weaponized
and then like given to people who can
use it for like a war against mutants if
one ever broke out but for Steven Lane
proper like like his whole plan here is
to basically like wipe out mute it's
like that's his whole thing he's part of
the anti mutant movement mutants are bad
we have to get rid of them they've got
to go all that kind of good stuff
again that's one of the big parts of
Chris Claremont storytelling is there
was a this kind of undercurrent that
went on all the time about anti-mutant
sentiment people were afraid of them and
so they were basically wanting to get
rid of them and with the x-men like
literally going through and initially
facing off against the Sentinels and and
basically overpowering like though the
one or two that are there they're
suddenly met by like a huge number of
them now this is something that
Claremont will toy with when it comes to
like Days of Future past right like the
reason why the signals were able to take
over North America in Days of Future
past is because there were just so many
of them it wasn't that they were just
like super powerful they were easy to
destroy the Incredible Hulk could easily
tear apart a signal but the Incredible
Hulk is gonna have a much
time when 200 of them come to sending
down on him then he's gonna die and like
that's that's exactly what happened in
Days of Future past but again like it's
one of these these cool things because
the Axman are kind of like overpowered
relatively fast um they do the best they
can and for the most part they're able
to hold their own but what this does is
it kind of switches back to earth and it
shows that kind of panic that the rest
of the x-men are going through and the
reason why is because while they're
talking to Peter Corbeau what they're
basically doing is they're using cerebro
to see whether or not they can locate
these mutants anywhere on earth and they
can't find the x-men and that's an
important thing and the reason why is
because when it comes to like checking
out the x-men on earth or looking for
mutants on earth nothing escapes cerebro
unless it's a being who's sufficient
enough in terms of like his vast power
to hide himself and that's when Peter
Cuervo comes to the realization that the
reason why cerebro can't find them is
because they're not on Earth is because
they're literally on an orbiting
satellite now this is where we kind of
get into this sort of personal plan of
Stephen Lang in terms of how it with how
it played out when Stephen Lang went to
the federal government and said like
look I'll take over the whole cinema
project what that did is it gave him the
resources or at least gave him the
information that he believed he had from
ball of our Trask but it was one thing
to have all that information on the
signals in like mutant genome and so on
and so forth it was another to be able
to do anything with it and so what he
ended up doing was basically going to
the inner circle of the Hellfire Club
which is like like Emma Frost and and
like Sebastian Shaw and those guys and
it's basically a group that exists for
the purpose of trying to control the
world from like invisible means right
like trying to control it from the
background but like what Stephen Lang
had done is he'd gone to the Hellfire
Club and basically said here's what I
want to do if you guys work with me then
like everything will be cool the
Hellfire Club gave him the money he
needed to literally get in a functional
orbital satellite that nobody could
detect and then in turn like fund his
whole Sentinel project in addition to
the money that the federal government
was giving him so he's really kind of
putting on a sham here light as far as
the federal government is concerned he's
doing what he's supposed to but in
reality he's doing a whole different
thing
another really kind of cool thing that
goes on here and again you're really
hitting on the nature of Clairmont
storytelling is it kind of switches over
to a news broadcast and the reason why
is when the x-men realized that the the
rest of the team are not on earth then
in turn like Peter Corbeau and then
basically aboard a shuttle and they take
off into space but one of the cool
things about this that you never really
see anymore in comics is you get this
kind of news blip that basically says
hey look like the world's going to pot
nobody trusts mutants anymore and like
everybody thinks they're bad it's really
cool because it kind of highlight
the nature of chris claremont
storytelling the fact you know has
focused so much on the actual story
itself focus on the characters were
really kind of pushing them in a forward
direction now the other half of this is
it around the time this is taking place
there's also a solar flare that's gonna
be emanating from the Sun and so what
this does is create a very dangerous
mission the x-men essentially have to
get in and out to rescue their teammates
before the solar flare hits if they
don't they're all gonna die is really
kind of what they're what they're
looking at there you talk about a solar
flare an astronomical amount of heat
literally sparking off the Sun and then
igniting the shuttle and probably
blowing it up or the very least cooking
them all alive and so once the group
makes their way aboard the orbital
satellite of Stephen Lang it kind of
gets taken care of pretty fast in this
sense it like Colossus and storm and all
those guys show up and basically start
wreaking havoc and wrecking the
Sentinels but in the middle of all this
what suddenly happens is that like
quote-unquote their teammates come out
and there is basically x-men vs. x-men
and it's kind of a cool little thing the
reason why is because this is the next
step in Steven Lang's plan that Steven
lanes idea was okay if the federal
government's me to work on signal
research then I'll do that and this is
the federal government side this is him
basically creating like cyborg
duplicates of the x-men now originally
we didn't know that like all we knew is
it was just like them facing off against
like classic x-men because they're all
dressed in the classic uniforms but
that's a big difference between Steven
laying and like how things are supposed
to be the problem with Steven Lankes
system right now is he's basically
running with incomplete information he's
running off all the information of all
of our Trask with no changes in between
not how they are now and a lot of the
x-men got a lot stronger over the years
and that's why it was when the signals
originally showed up instead of just
being able to like take the x-men x-men
and walk away and just be done with it
that they were kind of overpowered to a
degree in the beginning and it was
basically like hey look our signals
don't really prepare for this level of
power because Steven lanes didn't really
plan for it at all so again this is a
it's a cool little moment here because
for the most part once the x-men
realized what's going on and it's really
like Wolverine who makes the discovery
he literally like slices the robot
version of Jean Grey wide open and
exposes her robotic innards that and the
fact that like Charles Xavier is like
walking around and people are like what
in the heck is going on here but like
once the x-men basically like defeat
their robotic counterparts well then all
bets are off and just kinda like okay
fine like we're fighting robots here
everybody do your own thing and they
start tearing them all apart and
literally ripping everything to pieces
and so in this kind of last-ditch effort
you've literally got like Stephen Lang
kind of flying around like a like a
sonic boss like
yeah like dr. Robotnik in like this
little shuttle think trying to shoot the
shoot of the x-men trying to take them
out so on and so forth but for the most
part like he's his little vessels blown
up and then the x-men have to make their
escape and this is when the Phoenix saga
begins to kick in because what happens
here is that with this solar flare
approaching essentially like none of
them are gonna have the ability to
survive and so what Jean Grey does is
really kind of sacrifice her life in the
process and again this was building up
the character of Jean in the early days
she never would have done this because
she would've been like well you know I'm
too scared I don't know if I could do it
you know but now like with with Chris
Claremont running the show it's know she
can definitively do that like she's a
strong powerful confident woman she can
easily pull it off and so what she does
is literally scan the mind of Peter
Corbeau learn everything she needs to
know on how to pilot the shuttle she
shuts down the - Cyclops when he
intervenes the rest of the x-men go into
their pods and then she tells storm tell
Cyclops I love him and that's that it's
really the intention of sending her out
on like a hero's death and it's kind of
a cool little thing because when this
happens as Jean Grey starts to pilot the
shuttle she's basically flying back into
the atmosphere again at the same time
that this solar flare is beginning to
hit the ship and so the perception here
is that the entire x-men team is going
to die
that while Jean Grey does try to
sacrifice it really does does what she
can in order to keep the entire team
alive that they're all basically gonna
die the entire ship's gonna blow up and
so what this does is it brings an end to
the Frehley to the Phoenix saga with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
- comments explained make sure you guys
at the sub button - become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later purse
[Music]
you